[Musique]
ça va là bas
chers amis il est temps de se faire une
petite frayeur d'avoir un petit peu tard
il est vrai j'espère que vous passez
tous d'excellentes nuit malgré ces
vidéos seraient d'horreur comme on dit
en japonais
ben oui tu te faire plein de vidéos qui
sont pareils autant apprendre des mots
car voilà vous saurez les amis
aujourd'hui on va parler d'un ce cas
qu'est vraiment révolutionnaire alors il
est très vieux celui là mais mec il
m'avait choqué sa mère quand elle est
sortie en fait poursuit qui se demande
j'ai eu une période où j'étais fasciné
par le paranormal ça me fascine et je
prenais tout mais sans esprit critique
tout ce qu'on disait je croyais je
faisais ouais ouais à fantômes mois il a
fait voler tombale à travers la pièce
mais j'étais vraiment crédules comme on
dit mais aujourd'hui c'est fini
regardez la preuve le mec refuse
d'évoluer sur ça c'est incroyable il
s'agit d'un thread non pas sur twitter
mais sur reddit pour ceux qui
connaissent par résident c'est un site
extrêmement cool on peut parler de trucs
qu'on aime on peut voter pour pour ce
qui est de mieux former pire résumé de
la dite mais yes vous avez là dessus et
ça marche bien aussi alors j'espère que
tout le monde n'a pas suffi ce truc-là
l'époque sur la vidéo sert à rien ou
pire on va leur vivant sans moi je viens
de le relire et gelé revécu le truc
vraiment comme la première fois que j'ai
lu c'est génial aujourd'hui je vais vous
raconter l'histoire d'un type qui
s'appelle nhat hanh et qui a publié il
ya trois ans un gros ce raid sur reddit
natale commence on serait dans dix ans
qui vient de recevoir un autre message
on sait pas de quoi il parle que ce
message là est pire que les autres
éclats il a besoin de catalyser tout ça
dans un thread
mais de quoi parle-t-il data nous
explique que sa copine est morte le 7
août 2012 dans un accident de voiture
alors qu'elle revenait du travail plus
précisément il ya une voiture qui a
grillé un feu rouge à un carrefour et
qui rentrait dans la voiture de sa
copine et sa copine et décéder dans les
minutes qui ont suivi l'accident c'est
tragique natta nous dit qu au moment de
l'accident ça faisait presque cinq ans
qu'ils étaient ensemble que lui pense à
se marier avec elle mais elle n'était
pas très chaudes c'était pas trop son
délire mais n'atteint nous dit que si le
mariage était son délire il l'aurait
épousé au bout de trois mois de relation
il était fou amoureux d'elle nathan
prend le temps de nous dire que c'est
une fiche général qu'elle l'aimait
toucher à tout qu'elle adorait aussi
bien le camping que la technologie
qu'elle a toujours senti la cannelle
hayden plein de détails comme ça mais en
fait il nous dit qu'il a besoin de nous
décrire la personne formidable qu'elle
l'était avant de décrire autre chose de
beaucoup plus bizarre et étrange et ça
aura son importance plus tard donc
écoutez bien 4 septembre 2013 c'est là
où le cauchemar commence pour nathan
nathan a pris soin de laisser le compte
d' emilie ouvert comme si elle était
encore vivante pour pouvoir se balader
dans ses albums à l'écrit un petit
message sur son mur bref tout ce qui
peut lui rappeler sa bien aimée et lui
faire du bien voilà chacun sa manière de
faire son deuil et de d'essayer d'aller
mieux
jugera pas je sais pas si j'ai dit mais
sa copine à s'appeler emilie voilà si
jamais je suis une merde nathan nous dit
qu'il avait donné le mot de passe du
compte facebook de emilie à la maman
d'emilie qui s'appelle suzanne il
précise qu'elle va 0 sur l'ordi elle a
dû passer trois minutes sur facebook
sans rien comprendre ce qui se passait
mais bon voilà si jamais elle avait
besoin de faire comme nathan et d'aller
voir ses photos ses messages tout ça
elle pouvait le faire alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé le k de [ __ ] de
septembre 2013 le cas et bat emilie elle
a envoyé un message à nathan et oui
c'est pas terrifiant mais qu on voit un
morceau de conversations au dessus ça
c'est des messages qui lui envoyer
jusqu'en il avait besoin de lui parler
comme si elle était encore là et là
emilie répond bonjour oh [ __ ] ce à
quoi répond susan vous êtes sur le
compte d' emilie il a filé les comptes à
suzanne la maman d'émilie il se dit que
c'est sûrement elle et qu'elle a oublié
de ce déco et ruraux sur son compte elle
connaît pas trois technologies il a
raison il rationnalise il a raison mais
ce qu'il sait pas c'est que c'est
peut-être vrai - ok on continue à la je
sais que là où commence à vous dire en
cinq ans est intéressant cette histoire
nathan se précipitent alors ce son
téléphone pour appeler suzanne et lui
demander si c'est elle qui s'est
connecté au compte de sa fille et
suzanne lui dit qu'elle ne s'y est pas
connecté depuis la semaine où sa fille
est décédée
c'est chaud mec nathan se dit alors
qu'émilie connaissait beaucoup de monde
et que c'est sûrement l'un de ces pseudo
ami qui connaît un peu le game de la
technologie qu'à récupérer son mot de
passe qui veut juste le baiser de la
pire façon à lui faire du mal point le
16 novembre donc deux mois après le
premier message
emilie lui envoie un nouveau message à
lons se balader sur le sentier ce
dimanche nathan a pris soin de flouter
le sentier en question pour pas que les
gens il ya une qui retrouvait ruiz
habite bref la raison il se protège et
en voyant ça n'attend et remarque un
truc c'est que c'est des messages que
emilie a vraiment envoyé de son vivant
des mois auparavant il se rend compte
qu'en gros l'usurpateur d'identité qui
est sûr ce [ __ ] de compte ils
s'amusent à remonter à la conversation
et à remettre des messages qu'elle a
vraiment envoyé de son vivant un à temps
c'est horrible nathan répond alors bon
bordel tai chi ce à quoi emilie
répondent les roues du bus ce message
est chelou mais nathan nous précise
qu'en fait ça vient d'une discussion qui
a eu entre lui et emilie beaucoup plus
tôt quand il était en train de planifier
un road trip qui n'a jamais eu lieu
parce qu'elle est décédée avant
malheureusement est en gros il s'envoyer
des musiques à télécharger pour les
mettre dans la voiture pendant le road
trip nathan demande alors à la fosse
emilie de dire qui c'est qui fait ça et
là personne en face ne répond pas
pendant plusieurs mois vous imaginez il
ya quelqu'un tous les deux mois il
t'envoie un ou deux messages avec le
compte d'une personne qui est décédée et
apprécie énormément et tu sais pas qui
c'est trois mois plus tard en février
nathan il va sur facebook
qu'est ce qu'ils voient ils voient que
emilie ces tags et sur des photos de lui
et en arrivant sur la photo il
s'aperçoit que le tag ala où elle se
trouvait quand elle était encore vivante
et qu'ils étaient ensemble à
l'appartement même donc c'est hyper
glauque elle à nathan il se dit [ __ ]
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde là
ça devient vraiment glauque là on est
plus sur une simple blague de quelqu'un
qui se connecte sur un compte de la
personne pour s'envoyer des messages qui
est déjà très très chaud à faire quand
même faut vraiment être taré à partir de
là nathan il ya une réaction très
humaine ou dit que il dort presque plus
la nuit il est hyper en colère parce
qu'il sait toujours pas qui fait ça et
dans quel but et ça le rend ouf parce
que c'est abusé de faire ça ce truc là
ça a déclenché un autre problème c'est
que les amis d'amy lee ont vu qu'elle se
taguer sur des photos de nathan une
partie d'entre eux ont simplement pensé
qu'il s'agissait d'un bug informatique
comme il y en a tout le temps sur tous
les sites du monde ça peut arriver mais
problème c'est qu'une autre partie des
amis on pensait que c'était nathan qui
était en train de péter un câble de
tomber dans la folie et qui se connecter
sur le compte de sa copine pour
l'attaquer sur des photos de lui il a
donc perdu des potes qui trouvait ça
horrible qu'ils fassent ça alors qu'il
n'a jamais fait ça mais c'est aux rives
ou rendez compte déjà tu vis le truc tu
prend cher dans la gueule
et en plus tu perds des potes qui te
prennent pour un [ __ ] de psychopathe
c'est l'enfer un mois plus tard emilie
continue à être tagué sur des photos de
nathan et nathan décide d'envoyer un
message est ce qui suppose être le
hacker d'emilie dans son désespoir et
lui dit mec pourquoi tu fais ça pour
quoi tu continues de la tag et voilà
pour faire réagir lui montrer que c'est
juste triste de faire ça et ça lui fait
beaucoup de mal et c'est débile dix
jours plus tard nathan reçoit de
nouveaux messages elle lui envoie
plusieurs bons jours parce qu'ils
répondent pas au tac au tac nathan lui
dis que c'est vraiment dévastateur qui
comprend pas pourquoi cette personne
prend du plaisir à faire ça et là emilie
lui répond un truc un peu bizarre elle
lui dit ô mgd bougie parfumée à la
cannelle et on se souvient ce que nathan
a dit au début qu'elle sentait beaucoup
la cannelle nathan sous la colère lui
dit d'aller en enfer et emilie répond
pourquoi tu fais ça parallèlement à
sanaa temps ils allaient sur des forums
techniques pour trouver comment traquer
quelqu'un qui se connecte à un compte
facebook leur trouver avec l'adresse ip
il a même essayé de contacter facebook
bref il cherchait un moyen de trouver
qui était derrière ce [ __ ] de comptes
facebook lui a fait ce retour est en
fait les connections haut lieu sur son
pc ou celui de suzanne ou celui de son
bureau bref que des pc à lui en fait
d'où il ya que lui qui a accès donc qui
comprend pas il reçoit une nouvelle
vague de messages d'emilie y répond je
sais pas ce qui se passe je sais pas
pourquoi tu continues à faire ça s'il te
plaît arrête et c'est là où emilie va
lui répondre un truc qui va
définitivement faire flipper nathan ou
pour une fois il va commencer à se dire
[ __ ] c'est bizarre on dirait vraiment
que c'est médical comptait pas un
usurpateur emilie va réutiliser les mots
qui vient de dire s'il te plaît arrête
je ne sais pas ce qui se passe
nathan jeu
pas ce qui se passe comme si c'était
puis les phrases qui manquait ml pour
pouvoir dire un attend qu'elle comprend
pas ce qui se passe qu'elle ressemble
assez trop bizarre une semaine plus tard
emilie lui envoie les messages les plus
flippants qu'elle ait pu lui envoyer
dans cette conversation ça me fout le
cafard mon gars c'est à partir de là ça
part en couilles à lui envoyais avec une
étoile donc probablement un message de
nathan ou dès midi qui s'est corrigée
suit - 12 - 15 puis elle utilise une
phrase que l'un des deux s'étaient
envoyé auparavant comme d'habitude mon
pull et dans le sèche linge et il fait
très froid dehors vraiment froid dehors
froid froid
nathan s'il te plaît arrête hélas pour
la première fois elle compose un mot
avec des morceaux de mots et de phrases
clés dans la combe et à l'écrit freezing
qui veut dire glacial et puis elle
rebalance la fameuse phrase que nathan
lui avait dit je ne comprends pas ce qui
se passe mais at on nous dit qu'à partir
de là il commence à faire des cauchemars
parce que c'est un peu trop pour son
petit coeur il fait le même cauchemar en
boucle il rêve qu'elle est dans une
voiture bleue et grise gelée que lui se
trouve à l'extérieur de la voiture qui
frappent compte la ville ont eu 10 ans
or ce ressort rejoint mois et qu'elle le
regarde même pas elle n'entend pas et
les quais blot dans la voiture dans le
froid et c'est horrible bosses
simplement deux semaines plus tard
nathan semé une grosse caisse dans la
gueule il se bourrer littéralement la
gueule nathan lui envoie des messages il
le dit je suis vraiment bourré tu me
manques peu importe qui se connecte sur
ce compte j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je
continue à rentrer du travail à espérer
te voir sur l'ordinateur est ce que je
devrais pas être habitué à ça maintenant
la réponse des milliers à ça c'est ce
qui va pousser
nathan a transformé sa page en memoriam
c'est-à-dire son compte n'existe plus
c'est juste que des souvenirs les plus
possible d'envoyer des messages avec ce
compte là il ya plus toutes les photos
disparaissent il me semble bref c'est ce
qu'on fait quand une personne est
décédée pour lui rendre hommage et tout
le monde peut créer un petit mot sur le
mur j'espère vous avez jamais connu ça
autour de vous mais c'est possible de
faire ça sur facebook
et au final c'est une bonne chose je
trouve emilie lui a tout simplement
répondu
just let me roll qui veut dire laisse
moi juste marché pourquoi ça trouve
profondément nathan c'est une phrase qui
lui avait déjà envoyé quand elle était
encore vivante parce qu'il avait insisté
pour la ramener chez un ami sauf
qu'elles voulaient marcher donc je lui
avais dit laisse moi juste marcher bref
pourquoi dans ce contexte là c'est
glauque c'est parce qu'en fait lors de
l'accident de voiture les jambes des
mines et ont été sectionnés en diagonale
je vous épargne les détails mais c'est
horrible et c'est ce qui peut vraiment
rêver en plus dans un accident de
voiture dont conduisait avec prudence
qu'elle lui répondent
laisse moi juste marcher c'est pas
anodin pour lui et là ivry sa part
mémorial et malheureusement ça va être
encore pire pour lui après pour qu'on
comprenne ce qui se passe après nathan
nous envoie un screen de la conversation
le jour où emilie n'est pas rentré à la
maison parce qu'elle a eu son accident
habituellement elle rentrait tous les
jours du travail aux alentours de 16h et
la 17h30 a été toujours pas rentré donc
nathan seddiq
lui envoyer des messages pour prendre
des news il lui a demandé si elle était
sur le chemin du retour
puis lui a demandé de l'appeler quand
elle verrait ce message il dit qu'il a
appelé son taff et qui lui ont dit
qu'elle était partie à 16 heures qui
commence à paniquer il la supplie de
l'appeler deux heures après la thur pas
news il lui dit réponse de platon
téléphone mais au fond il comprend pas
ce qui s'est passé deux mois après le
message disant qu'elle voulait marcher
elle lui renvoie des trucs et là elle
utilise qu'il a dit dans la conversation
le jour elle est décédée où elle
rentrait pas du travail
elle lui dire hey tu es sur le chemin du
retour emilie quand tu vois ce message
s'il te plaît rappelle moi tout de suite
s'il te plaît arrête je commence à
paniquer s'il te plaît arrête froid je
sais pas ce qui se passe froid gelé
bordel de merde les dernières news qu'il
a c'est ce que je viens de vous dire et
c'est la veille du jour où ils postent
sur reddit l'histoire alors les gens
vont lui donner des tas de conseils
voulu dire mec vraiment ça va faire un
an tu es dans cette merde arrête coupe
to quit facebook stop sauf que nathan il
a envie de comprendre qui est en face de
lui qu'il fait cette blague depuis un an
qui le hantent en fait littéralement
deux mois après le dernier message
disant qu'elle voulait juste marcher
nathan a transformé sa page facebook en
mémorial est là il reçoit une
notification facebook alors nathan ils
l'ouvrent ce [ __ ] de messages et il
tombe sur une photo de lui sur son
ordinateur prise de l'extérieur de sa
maison
là il faut appeler la police a vraiment
aucun doute et à partir de là on n'a
plus aucune nouvelle il à arrêter de
raconter ce qui s'est passé on sait pas
ce que c'était ça se trouve il a tout
simplement arrêté d'ouvrir sa [ __ ] de
page facebook est de se faire du mal à
tête qu'il a fermé le compte facebook
dès midi et le sien aussi et qui passe
définitivement à autre chose
on sait pas comment ça se termine et
c'est frustrant bordel de merde mais
d'un autre côté et on espère juste qu'il
va mieux qui écrivait ces [ __ ] de
messages avec le comte d'emilie est-ce
que c'est emilie elle même ou est ce que
c'est quelqu'un d'autre qui est un petit
malin qui est peut-être chez pas moi le
frère d'emilie qui du coup était sur le
pc de la maman ou quelqu'un à son bureau
un collègue qui aime pas du tout nathan
et qui va sur son pc et qui est un peu
fort en informatique gens on n'en sait
rien n'hésitez pas à bien dormir cette
nuit a aimé la vidéo si c'est le clip
tueur de threads vous plaît si vous
aimez un peu que laisserait de soi
variés comme ça que ce soit pas tout le
temps la même mécanique que ce soit des
trucs différents comme la gc au maximum
de variés que ça continue de capter
votre attention et vous auriez pris par
les histoires mois celle-ci je trouve
génial la mécanique est génial aussi je
suis trop fan et c'est la mission que ça
peut tellement arriver cette merde ça me
fait flipper je suis pourtant moi j'ai
énormément rationaliser les choses mais
quand je lis une histoire comme ça
j'avoue chaud quand même transporter je
me dis [ __ ] c'est ouf
donc voilà je continuerai à faire des
petits traits d'horreur comme ça
temps en temps je kiffe trop je vous
fais des gros bisous je vous dis à
bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo portez
vous bien et surtout bonne nuit
[Musique]